pour
on va
ce soir cinq centièmes d'un livre un
jour je ne pouvais vous proposer qu'une
émission un peu différente et un plateau
vraiment exceptionnel ils sont sept
écrivains qui nous font l'amitié d'être
avec moi ce soir et pour une fois de
s'exprimer à ma place ce sont tous les
sept d'éminents représentants de cette
république des lettres dont diderot
remarquait déjà qu'elle est en france
honorées commandes aucun autre pays
voici donc michel déon irène frain
alexandre jardin
jacques lanzmann françois nourissier
jean d'ormesson
robert sabatier je vais vous demander de
nous donner en 30 secondes une ou deux
bonnes raisons de lire le dernier
ouvrage que vous avez publié est d'abord
michel déon pour page grecque chez
gallimard
taj gray que c'est un recueil de notes
de souvenirs d'histoire connectés en
grèce depuis plus de trente ans j'ai
vécu là-bas de nombreuses années j'étais
absolument envoûté par ce pays que j'ai
profondément aimé j'en ai tiré une
substantifique mal dans beaucoup de
livres et cette fois ci j'ai voulu
réunir ce qui est la description même de
la grèce de ces histoires de ce mythe et
la phase se termine sur la tâche
d'aujourd'hui
ce qui me fait un petit peu moins
optimiste pour l'avenir de la casse
merci irène frain des vies donc c'est
suivre une femme bandits qui a fait la
une de tous les journaux de l'âne
pendant deux ans qui était poursuivi par
toutes les polices c'est une femme
amoureuse c'est une femme passionnée
c'est une bande grèce et c'est judith
c'est antigone et c'est beaucoup de
souffrance de passion et pour moi de
souvenirs puisque elle est encore
vivante est présente dans mon coeur oui
c'est tout à fait ça effectivement
alexandre jardin le petit sauvage chez
gallimard je vous en déconseille
vivement la lecture
je veux vous avez raison ce que parce
que j'essaie d'écrire un livre qui
rendent imprudent et imprévisible donc
si vous espérez continuer à mener une
vie tranquille ne lisait pas mon book
besoins de la télévision
et si par hasard votre femme vous ai pas
encore quitté surtout de lui offrait pas
tomber tant elle l'a lu jacques lanzmann
le dieu des papillons chez lattès
d'abord c'est très dur de parler de son
livre qui vient de sortir en trente
secondes on a envie de parler longtemps
mais je dirai je ne veux pas défendre
mais je dirais que j'ai écrit ce livre
avec passion et que je veux qu'il soit
lu passionnément
il ya déjà 60 mille personnes qu'ils ont
entre les mains est davantage même
moment et que c'est très important
d'être bien reçu c'est à dire sa portion
de biens donnés est important d'être
bien reçu voilà françois nourissier le
gardien de gardiens des ruines pardon
chez grasset je dirais que une une
chanson ces composés de parole et de
musique est ce qu'on retient ce ne sont
pas les paroles c'est toujours l'air
c'est toujours la musique qu'on
chantonne et avec le gardien des ruines
ce que je voudrais c'est n'ont pas
évoqué le sujet mais dire simplement que
j'ai essayé de composer un roman qui
laisse comme un souvenir de deux de
musique parce que les paroles les
paroles qu'est ce que c'est dans un
roman c'est l'histoire c'est l'anecdote
et les personnages chez le sujet alors
que la musique c'est le style c'est
l'espèce d'allégresse qu'on met dans
l'écriture c'est une certaine façon
d'accélérer et de freiner de repartir
et tout ça qu'on ressent en écrivant je
voudrais essayer de faire passer chez le
lecteur
c'est une mélodie c'est je crois la
bonne définition de ce livre jean
d'ormesson le vent du soir et deux
autres romans chez lattès oh mon dieu
peut-être pourrait-on dire que c'est un
roman feuilleton mais planétaire
on répète tout le temps que le monde a
plus changé en 100 ans qu'au cours de
tout les millénaires qui l'ont précédé
et bien c'est le roman du monde moderne
c'est le roman de la machine à vapeur de
l'avion des guerres loyalement de la
dictature c'est un roman feuilleton
moderne il ya 4 heures très belle
il s'appelle le jeu mélangeant à vanessa
jessica atalante à ya quatre frères tout
le monde se courent après et puis on
voit passer
erdil claire steimer pas moins très bien
robert sabatier olivier ses amis chez
albin michel
bah moi je me suis bien amusé en
l'écrivant nous lit un passage
la conversation se poursuivit avec des
débauches de fricassée de ragoût de
frichti de rôti le pot-au-feu la
blanquette de veau le boeuf mode ou
bourguignon la potée les prix la voilà
c'est le roman tel que je peut le
définir
il ya à boire et à manger du fou
j'espère que c'est bon bayonne lectrices
qui m'a écrit vous êtes un romancier qui
me rend heureuse
je suis très content voilà cela pose et
si on lis je serai ravi écoutez vous
parlez bonheur nous on est vraiment très
très heureux de vous avoir réuni sur ce
plateau
merci infiniment de vous être prêté à
cet exercice relativement complexe qui
consiste à parler brièvement de quelque
chose que l'on a aimé
c'est un exercice que je ne méconnais
pas comme vous le savez à bientôt et
merci encore